I’ve been using the Samsungs new Galaxy
buds, and I’m way more impressed than I
thought they would be.
I started off with the S10+, where the setup
process was familiar but less fluid than my
Airpod’s, and after I was greeted with the
Galaxy wearable app that allowed me to change
the EQ for all audio which is something I’ve
wanted since the Airpods were released.
I enjoyed using them with the Android Phone,
and that got me thinking.
Are the Galaxy buds worth buying and using
as an alternative to the Airpods, if you own
an iPhone?
To get it right out there, Yes, I think for
a lot of iOS users the Galaxy buds may be
a better buy, but not for everyone, and I’ll
tell you why in just a bit.
Let's start out with the first enticement
with the buds, and that's the price.
$129 isn’t that much lower than the $159
Apple charges for their super successful Airpod’s,
but if you care about wireless charging that
will cost you another $40, $70 more than the
Galaxy buds that come with wireless charging
built in.
Not everyone cares about that, but what does
matter to all is battery life.
The Galaxy buds last 6 hours instead of the
5, but the charging chase only offers 7 additional
hours compared to close to 20 with the Airpods.
The Cradle cases work similarly, but the Galaxy
buds is larger overall.
The next enticement is the sealed design with
multiple earbud and wing tips to make sure
you get a great seal and fit.
Even though the AirPods fit me perfectly,
This has been the biggest complaint I’ve
heard about them for those who they don’t
fit and a huge reason for an iPhone user to
go with the Galaxy buds.
Another thing I love is the fact that they
are practically flush with my ears when I
have them in, meaning I can use them with
a helmet on.
The sealed design is great for a time where
you want to cut down background noise and
even partially protect your hearing.
If you're using an Android device you’ll
have an ambient sound feature, but since we
don’t have the Galaxy wearable app in iOS
that will be missing.
Along with that, you won’t have an all-around
EQ controller but the Airpods don’t have
this either, instead, you can make adjustments
on an App basis.
Honestly, I didn’t find that I needed to
since the default settings were my favorite
out of the options Samsung gives.
The highs are crisp, mids are balanced, and
the bass is worlds ahead of the AirPods thanks
to the sealed design.
If you care about sound quality, the Galaxy
buds are definitely ahead and sound impressive
for the price.
So we have a lower price, wireless charging,
compact design, better sound and fit for most,
and along with that an IPX2 for sweat and
light spash resistance, but what are the downsides
if you use them with an iPhone?
The biggest one for me is the fact that they
aren’t as seamless as the AirPods with the
W1 or H1 chip.
I love that the AirPods automatically get
added to all of my iCloud devices and I just
open the case, put them in, and they auto
pair.
You won’t get this same fluid experience
but it's still not bad.
The work like any other Bluetooth headphones
so connect them once to each device and then
if you want to switch from your Mac to the
iPhone go into the Bluetooth settings and
manually hit connect.
In the batteries widget you’ll see the battery
life but unfortunately, it's not broken down
into each bud and you also can’t see the
case’s charge level like you can with the
AirPods.
On the plus side, you can still single tap
to pause and unpause, double tap to skip a
song, and even hold down to invoke Siri.
You can also use the built-in Mic’s just
like with any Bluetooth devices.
Overall, I’m very impressed with the Galaxy
buds.
The sound quality and feature set is fantastic
for the price and even if you’re using an
iPhone they are a great option with very little
downsides compared to Apple’s offering so
I can confidently say Yes they are worth it
for iPhone users.
This has been Max with MaxTech if you want
to see more videos like this hit that little
circle above and let me know if you’d consider
picking up the Galaxy buds in the comments
section below.